Papa way two days on the 2015 bubble
calendar after you place the final piece
on your 1000 color CMYK puzzle because
it's episode 48 of Luke wake up in
midair inside a tree tent tentsile
portable treehouses combine hammocks
with tents to provide shelter without
being affected by topography wetness
lumps or bumps just make sure you're
wearing a sleeping bag silk bag is an
award-winning sleepwear system designed
to give maximum mobility and comfort
inspired by Chilean nomads no matter
what card game you play use this
developers code deck which includes
programming languages like PHP CSS and
C++ see plush slippers on your feet
whether they're zombie heads Godzilla
feet or Freudian slip purse grizzly bear
bean bag log pillow meat pillow skull
chair cherish the human skull with this
full-size cardboard sculpture made out
of 50 layers for you to assemble he
comes in brown white black and zebra and
his name is Vince convince yourself this
candle will have a treasure inside one
in 50 pop-up Diamond candles contained a
0.10 carat diamond randomly inserted
into the wax mold by the president of
the pop-up paris company invite company
over and show them your bucket of doom a
storytelling card game in which you
attempt to escape fatal scenarios using
useless objects like you've been buried
alive in an airtight coffin and you
somehow hatch your escape using a
didgeridoo yourself a favor and organize
your relatively dirty desk
thanks to this genius paperclip holder
and reinvent your keychain using the key
port a compact device that replaces
oddly shaped keys with key port blades
so no more key jingling or scratching
and you can also include a bottle opener
or flash drive drive mug muggers away by
using the plug coffee mug which features
a removable plug that renders the mug
useless for anyone
clam purse and clip clothes like a
daredevil by hiring the amazing peg zeny
family to employ that old-timey high
wire way to dry laundry water your
plants the futuristic way with plant
weed a soil free indoor smart garden
featuring an intelligent light system
and automatic watering pump to grow
herbs salad greens and edible flowers
all year round so you'll always have
plenty of time to solve your crossword
puzzle clock cross homemade Twinkies off
your to-do list and add some personality
with edible eyes that feature 10
different expressions per pack then pack
your skull and bones cloth for a
never-ending trip into the infinite
dungeon corridor a medieval spin on the
infinity mirror that showcases a torch
lined corridor that stretches on forever
but before you go learn a bit about the
stars above by studying to know your
stars unique cube and once you're able
to recognize telescope iam from Aries
you're ready to tell the world that's it
I'm off to outer space
and as always thanks for watching
encase your brain and Vsauce with
official Vsauce beanies from beard oh
just make sure you add the code Vsauce
to get 50% off which is like half off
it's like it's like like 50% man